good Parliament special committee on tax
rulings lead the charge to crack down on
the so-called sweetheart tax deals made
between EU governments and
multinationals two months into the
investigation the committee is facing
obstacles we asked for elements we asked
for documentation and we are waiting for
those documents to arrive we invited all
the ministers of finance from the 28
member states and if they wanted to come
and speak to us the dodgy deals and
aggressive tax avoidance done at times
of high austerity aren't in themselves
illegal just highly immoral at a public
hearing em ep's once again called on the
media for help sanuk goo see ya amante
de precio loopy on public at avila media
canoes Urban League of a limo ah boochie
but making States accountable can come
with a price one deluxe leaks
whistleblowers and a French journalists
have been indicted in luxembourg it
would be very good if this committee
would already pick up the question of
whistleblowers protection one of the
topics that has been discussed today
there would be a really good point to us
that this discussion keeps on going
within the EU bodies also after the end
of the mandate of the special committee
the special committees report is
expected on G in the 22nd